trois attaques peut-être cette nous
dit-on de source policière en tout cas
au moins trois ont été perpétrés à paris
et autour de paris
on n'a jamais connu un attentat comme ça
dans les rues de paris on n'a jamais été
confronté à une action ans de guerre
[Musique]
c'est la guerre avec l'odeur de la
poudre du sang la vision c'est la guerre
on pense pas trop hein soit on l'a on
essaie surtout de prendre les bonnes
décisions
déterminées qui a fait quoi
très bon
avec qui et pourquoi
c'est une toile le coin s'est passé
tellement énorme je pars de trois
personnes qui nous ont tiré dessus un an
après on me parle d'une quantité de gens
on me parle du financement des armes de
tout devient énorme
45000 code 45 mille pièces de procédure
mille sept cent quarante parties civiles
et 350 avocat ce jour au moins six mois
d'audiences dans une salle de 600 places
spécialement construite au coeur du
palais de justice de paris
c'est un procès de très grande ampleur
et qui donc n'est comparable à rien ce
procès en appel choix il doit être
historique
que n'at-on pas fait que n'at-on pas
empêché comment ces attentats ont ils pu
se produire
c'est la liberté qui aura le dernier mot
vous avez agi de manière effroyable vous
allez être condamné de manière
démocratique
[Musique]
bon ça c'est la dernière photo de l'ania
deux heures avant
à deux heures après elle était à la
belle équipe
donc ça ce sont ces en août 2015 donc il
lui fait voilà il ya une série de quatre
photos
voilà avec un poème qu'une de ces
grandes cousy une bande cousine
voilà un a écrit parce que la mia en
fait c'était voilà la mia coeur de paris
lamia fleurs de paris effectivement
c'était la plus parisienne de mes
enfants
le deuil on connaissait déjà enfin dans
la vie et même le deuil de personnes de
notre âge a donc dd2 difficile on n'en
avait connue
mais là la problématique on comprend pas
tout de suite que la problématique va
être toute autre c'est les circonstances
de la mort c'est jean-jacques il est pas
mort dans un accident de voiture il est
pas mort d'un infarctus jean-jacques il
était assassiné alors à quel moment je
me dis l'enquète pris vite moi
personnellement c'est moi qui suis plus
dans dans cette quête de
juridique où j'avais été voir un avocat
parce que je savais qu'il y avait tout
de suite je pensais qu'ils allaient
avoir un procès clair je veux savoir
qui sont ces
bons hommes qui sont qui ont fait
intrusion dans notre vie c'est pour moi
c'est ça ils ont fait intrusion donc
pour moi il n'y a pas de souci je veux
dire je n'ai pas je n'ai pas cette étude
joue réellement temps je passe à
maintenant je veux savoir qui tu es d'où
tu viens de comment tuer pourquoi tu
fais ça avec qui tu es en fait qui tuer
qu'ils tuent et pour avoir tué
ah ah
[Musique]
dès le début pendant les attaques
finalement le procureur mots là on se
rend sur les lieux le procureur molas
incarne la justice aux yeux des français
et le procureur mollins montre à
l'ensemble de la société que la justice
ait laquelle le vase prendre en charge
cette affaire qu'elle va s'en occuper je
pense que c'est bien ça évite aux
victimes de se dire qu'elles vont devoir
faire ce travail
moi j'ai tout de suite ressenti un
besoin
fort pressent évident d'être au plus
près de l'événement pour être sûr
d'avoir un maximum d'informations ce qui
me permettait par le maire décision
possible donc en réalité j'ai décidé
tout de suite de deux sortes de partir
de chez moi pour aller sur les lieux
pour voir ce qui se passe ces
[Musique]
informations sur les auteurs de ces
attaques est ce qu'ils ont tous été
neutralisée vous allez un peu trop vite
je vous confirme d'abord que
le parquet le parquet de paris s'est
saisie donc d'une enquête en crime
flagrant en matière terroriste
on va s'attacher à déterminer ce qui
s'est passé déterminer le profil de ces
terroristes savoir le parcours qui a été
fait savoir s'il ya encore des complices
ou des coauteurs dans la nature et vous
serez bien évidemment comme dans chaque
affaire de ce type régulièrement
informés pour ce qui concerne sa
compétence judiciaire par le parquet de
paris je peux rien vous dire de plus
il ya tout un tas de missions qui vont
se se juxtaposer s'additionnaient donc
organisé l'envoi de techniciens en scène
de crime sur scène de crime organisé
l'envoi de magistrats du parquet sur
chacune de ses scènes de crime il faut
ensuite coordonner l'activité des
services de police tout en garantissant
la sécurité juridique de toutes ces
opérations
c'est à ce moment là que l'on va
recueillir un solde indices notamment
pour pouvoir démontrer qui a pu
participer à quoi retrouver parfois une
empreinte retrouvée un élément d'un
téléphone portable retrouvé un élément
qui a salué une arme un véhicule une
patte d'immatriculation tout cela va
avoir une importance capitale pour la
suite plus vous êtes réactif voir
proactif puis - vous prendrez de retard
et mieux vous pourrez remplir vos fils
[Musique]
non
à la soirée du 13 novembre 2015 et bien
sûr gravé dans ma mémoire dans la
mémoire de beaucoup de magistrats et
notamment des magistrats parisiens nous
passons la nuit ici parce que se met en
place la cellule de crise au parquet de
paris
malgré le choc le chaos tout le monde
est à son poste tout le monde est au
travail
[Musique]
ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé que je
n'oublierai jamais c'est le nombre de
messages de magistrats de ce tribunal
qui me disent très spontanément par sms
je me tiens à la disposition de la
justice de mon pays est bien évidemment
j'ai de la notion que avec des attentats
ayant provoqué la mort de 130 personnes
c'est évident que j'aurai besoin de tout
le monde
[Musique]
comme je suis revenu au parquet près les
passages en salle du bataclan je vais
arriver dans une salle qui est noir
demande tout le monde est déjà en
situation tout le monde est en train de
travailler les ateliers sont en place la
salle est en place et donc le dispositif
est opérationnel
[Musique]
vous avez un chrono qui est tenu par un
magistrat ou fonctionnaire qui va avoir
la charge de noter effectivement tous
les événements qui se passent et qui
sont projetées sur un écran et puis
après vous avez des ateliers dont le
type ou la répartition peut varier en
fonction des attentats
c'est à dire un groupe de magistrats
structurée hiérarchisée
organisé qui vont se répartir le travail
immédiatement avec chacun des
interrupteurs spécifiques les uns pour
la police scientifique les autres pour
les victimes les troisièmes en charge
des premières orientations des
investigations d'autres de l'aspect
international avec une remontée ensuite
d'information qui permet de structurer
l'action poursuivre effectivement en
direct et pouvoir analyser au plus près
toutes les informations et tous les
procès verbaux qui remonte dans la part
de services de police ont été saisis
la machine judiciaire au sens
effectivement mobilisation d'une équipe
se met en route avant minuit ça c'est
clair et ce seront finalement plus de
soixante magistrats de tout le parquet
de paris qui seront mobilisés pour la
gestion de cette affaire la cellule de
crise durera une dizaine de jours pour
mesurer tout ce que ça représente
je pense qu'on est à un peu plus d'un
millier d'officiers police judiciaire
qui vont être affectés à ce dossier qui
vont travailler sur ce dossier et
investigués
c'est le choc nerveux
[Musique]
néanmois cette affaire a révélé des
fragilités du dispositif la justice
n'était pas forcément préparé un si
grand nombre de victimes est donc un si
grand nombre de corps à gérer
nous avons dû suivre ce parcours du
combattant que beaucoup de parents comme
nous ont dû
parcourir il y avait ces numéros d'appel
spéciaux mais on tombait en général sur
une musique ou sur où ça sonnait dans le
vide parce qu'il y avait tellement
d'appels qui évidemment une personne ne
pouvait suffire à répondre à tous à la
fin j'ai quelqu'un qui me répond est
très calme très rassurant en me disant
ne vous inquiétez pas là le nom de la
mia n'est pas sur les listes vous ne
rappelait pas trois fois il me l'a dit
j'attendais que ça qui me disent ne
rappelait pas nous vous rappellerons
sylla le nom émerge pour moi ce que je
me dis comment quand je vois le nombre
de membres il ya combien de personnes au
bataclan dibaya 1500 personnes à ce
moment là il ya 50 morts donc
je me dis mon sabre à 1550
dans ma tête mon frère il a toujours eu
assez de chance donc
je me demande où va le retrouver je
pense que je croyais pas à sa mort
parce qu'on entend par les infos que il
ya des erreurs est des gens qui sont
annoncés morts alors c'est pas les
bonnes personnes donc moi je pense que
oui on nous annonce son décès mais
tant qu'on ne voit pas c'est pareil
c'est pas que un c'est pas on y croit
toujours un peu en fait à 8 heures du
matin ils n'ont toujours pas appelé donc
pour moi c'est ça va au point que il ya
sur facebook parce qu'on utilise un peu
facebook était déjà mis une imposte pour
dire les familles endeuillées et j'en
vois moi aussi ma sage oublierai jamais
j'en vois aussi mon mon mot de
solidarité avec toutes les familles
endeuillées bien sûr
j'ai ouvert comme je lai indiqué hier
aux journalistes une enquête en
flagrance des chefs d'assassinât en
bande organisée en relation avec une
entreprise terroriste
ainsi que pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes criminels de
nature à commettre des crimes d'atteinte
aux personnes on peut à ce stade des
investigations dire que très
vraisemblablement ce sont trois équipes
de terroriste coordonnée qui sont à
l'origine de cette barbarie
[Musique]
alors en fait ce qui va se passer le
soir du 13 novembre il ya deux kamikazes
dans qui vont mourir au stade de france
donc c'est ahmad al mohammad et mohamed
al mahmoud puis bill à la fille qui vont
faire sauter autour des différentes
portes du stade de france
il y aura une personne qui va décéder
très nombreux blessés il faut pas
l'oublier donc c'est pas que j'en
attends pas rater
ensuite il ya trois terroristes qui vont
mourir au bataclan donc c'est ça miami -
semaine mostefaï et fois d'ahmed à gad
[Musique]
et enfin il ya le commando qui a attaqué
les terrasses donc ce commando est il y
avait abdelamid about bien sûr il y
avait son ami chakib à bout il y avait
brahim abdeslam le frère de salles
abdeslam
brahim abdeslam va se faire sauter au
comptoir voltaire et ensuite trois
personnes prennent la fuite abdelhamid
about et chakib akrou et séparément
salades des sabres
tout le monde et je dirais dans les
starting blocks pour à la fois conduire
les investigations et mener la traque
des fugitifs
nous avons été amenés au niveau du
parquet de paris à saisir dès la nuit
dernière le parquet fédéral belge donc
le parquet fédéral antiterroriste aux
belges de quatre demandes don't rain
pénale internationale et en particulier
une demande d'entraidé pénale a visé ce
véhicule paulo retrouver devant le
bataclan
[Musique]
en soi molas me contacter en dix ans
frédéric nous avons des plaques
d'immatriculation belges ils ont
retrouvé la voiture près du bataclan
c'est du belge donc voilà je vais te
contacter il va y avoir des infos donc
mais le maximum là dessus et dès la nuit
on est on est mobilisé là dessus tout
je suis juge d'instruction il avait le
panneau juge d'instruction tribunal de
première instance de bruxelles et je
suis magistrat spécialiste en matière de
terrorisme
dès le lendemain 10 le 14
jti saisie par le procureur fédéral en
vue d'instruire à charge de x ou bats
qui pour des faits de participation aux
activités d'un groupe terroriste est
assassiné à caractère terroriste parce
que très rapidement les liens entre la
belgique et les attentats de paris vont
ressortir très rapidement il cotait
alors à la désignation d'un juge
d'instruction s'impose et donc dès ce
moment là commence une phase où on est
dans le match dans le mode chasse à
l'homme
salle abdeslam donc est un ami d'enfance
d'abdelhamid abou oud leur maison était
mitoyenne et about lui ne vivaient pas
là mais par contre il y avait le
commerce de son père
les très rap de sam et ils sont connus
pour des faits de stupéfiants ils ont un
mode de vie qui se situe aux antipodes
du coran tel qu'interprété par
l'organisation de l'état islamique et
donc ils ne sont pas dans le radar qui
nous occupe à ce moment là le radar du
terrorisme
salle abdeslam va servir un peu de taxis
ou différents terroristes il va aller
chercher un peu partout en europe
les futurs commando du 13 novembre
[Musique]
oh
le soir du 13 salles abdeslam après
avoir déposé le commando du stade de
france il remonte vers le 18ème
arrondissement de paris où il laisse sa
voiture ainsi que l'ensemble de ces
armes il ne conserve que sa ceinture
explosive
[Musique]
parce qu'on sait c'est qu'à 22h30 il va
acheter une puce de téléphone qu'il
active et il rentre en contact très
rapidement avec deux amis à lui qui sont
en belgique des dealers de shit des
délinquants de droit commun pas du tout
des grands chefs de l'état islamique un
pas du tout et ensuite va s'ensuivre une
un périple que je trouve assez étonnant
il va faire une boucle qui contourne
paris qui suit le périphérique parisien
par l'ouest pour se retrouver dans le
sud parisien à châtillon où il va se
retrouver dans une cité à l'evo banc
dans les hauts-de-seine
moi il ya une chose qui interroge et
j'aimerais bien comprendre on parle d'un
belge qui est venu rarement à paris à
part dans les jours qui sont venus
précédemment pour nous et les
appartements conspiratif la belgique
l'autoroute 1 c'est le plein oeuvre
porte de la chapelle il laisse sa
voiture à quelques centaines de mètres
de la porte de la chapelle il appelle
deux amis qui doit venir le chercher de
bruxelles dont qui vont arriver dans ce
train là et qu'est-ce qui fait il
traverse tout paris pour se retrouver
plein suite
alors moi je ça m'interroge je sais que
ça a beaucoup interrogés les services
qui ont beaucoup pensé qu'ils pouvaient
avoir espéré avoir un relais dans ce
coin
une fois châtillon il s'est caché dans
les parties communes d'un immeuble de la
cité vauban et on vend deux adolescents
les qui va discuter qui se rendent pas
du tout content son comportement ne
montre pas particulièrement c'est
quelqu'un qui vient de participer en
attentats de masse
on sait aussi qui s'est débarrassé de sa
ceinture d'explosifs à quelques
centaines de mètres derrière cet
immeuble
et à 4 heures du matin les adolescents
kit salle abdeslam et on sait maintenant
que à
5h30 du matin ses deux amis belges sont
présents et le récupère pour le remonter
vers la belgique
rappel l'état d'urgence est décrété par
le président de la ré de la république
dans la nuit l'eau à ce moment-là il
annonce l'état d'urgence mais il annonce
aussi un renforcement important du
contrôle aux frontières et ensemble de
dispositifs sont mis en place
à 9h10 les gendarmes au niveau de
cambrai décide de d'arrêter le véhicule
suspect ils sont quelque chose qui n'est
pas très clair on est quelques heures
après les attentats du 13 et voilà il
trouve que c'est pas naturel les
gendarmes font traîner un petit peu les
choses prennent en photo la carte
d'identité
voilà fois un contre un peu plus poussée
qu'à l'ordinaire un moment donné on leur
dit de relâcher la voiture la voiture
repart et quelques dizaines de minutes
plus tard coup de téléphone ouais ce
gendarme en dix ans interpellé à salah
abdeslam que vous venez de contrôler et
évidemment les gendarmes avaient relâché
salah abdeslam depuis quelques temps il
était impossible de le retrouver oui il
y a un petit raté
landman un croc raté même le lendemain
de de l'attenté du bataclan lorsque il
est arrêté par nos propres forces de
sécurité sur l'autoroute à et qu' il est
procédé à la vérification son identité à
l'interrogation des autorités policières
belge qui nous indique qu'il ne
représente pas de danger qu'on peut le
laisser partir salah abdeslam est
signalé
les français qui les services de police
français qu'ils interceptent voit qu'il
est signalé pose la question mais le
laisse partir avant d'avoir la réponse
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que dans
la boîte à gants de la voiture qu'on
retrouve devant le bataclan ce 13
novembre vous avez tous les papiers de
location de la voiture
si on avait ouvert la boîte à gants on
aurait trouvé des papiers de location de
véhicules 90 salles abdeslam ils ont
retrouvé le lendemain après les
contrôles le lendemain il est déjà
revenu
je crois à schaerbeek enfin bruxelles et
donc
et dépasser entre les mâles que ça soit
la faute des bd français que ce soit la
faute des belges que ce soit la faute de
qui vous voulez ça ne change rien je
dois retrouver des hauteurs et je dois
les interpeller afin qu'ils répondent de
leurs actes devant les juridictions
françaises
on va pouvoir remonter et le retrouver
la piste entre autres à travers les
contrôles véhicules et des caméras de
vidéosurveillance des stations de
service
[Musique]
il arrive en belgique et la première
chose qu'il fait il cherche un coiffeur
abdeslam ne se contente pas de changer
de coupe de cheveux il va sur un marché
il achète des vêtements et il change de
look exactement comme sid ahmed lahm
devait changer de look avant pendant et
après son attentat on retrouve là
toujours les mêmes préceptes de la
cellule des opex c'est vraiment des
réflexes d'agents secrets et ensuite il
va souhaiter entrer en relation avec un
autre ami qui aussi mises en cause et
c'est annie ensuite le père de vue le
déposant voiture et on perd à ce moment
là complètement salam décemment
[Musique]
c'est une grande ville bruxelles ses
amis l'ont 250000 habitants plus ou
moins ça la baie saint bénigne et un
bruxellois c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours vécu à bruxelles qui connaît
bien bruxelles c'est quelqu'un qui
bénéficie d'un réseau social
d'amis et très rapidement le dossier des
mains sur des interpellations
premiers inculpés mohamed ambri et hamza
à tous interpellés durant le week end
qui suit les attentats il aurait
véhicules et entre paris et bruxelles le
suspect est toujours en fuite salah
abdeslam ali ou le caddie lui aussi a
transporté salle abdeslam de laeken à
schaerbeek les deux amis salle abdeslam
qui vont venir le chercher à paris et
ensuite celui qui valident également sur
grossesse m'arrêter très rapidement mais
ça l'a mené slam à leur à nouveau
échappés
[Musique]
cet autre hypothèse qui surgit ce soir
celle d'un deuxième homme en fuite un
deuxième homme en fuite un autre membre
du commando qui a fait feu sur les
terrasses des restaurants à ce moment là
les services français recherche de
personnes l'eurobasket orange on a vu
sur des vidéos et des vidéos des
terrasses et qu'on voit ensuite dans des
vidéos de vidéosurveillance de la ratp
bizarrement on parle beaucoup moins
chakib akroum étaient présents à côté de
lui je pense que les services ont voulu
préserver cette source d'information en
effet abdelhamid about est vu à 22h14 à
la station de métro croix de chavaux en
compagnie d'un second individu non
identifié
donc on sait maintenant que chakib
accroc et abdel hamid daoud ont trouvé
refuge dans des buissons aubervilliers
si je me trompe pas prêts dans une zone
un peu industrielle est caché
il contacte assez rapidement des gens en
belgique il va sans doute donner les
coordonnées de sa cousine qui habite à
côté de saint denis qui va venir
chercher about avec une de ses amies
et en fait l'ami donc de cette cuisine
va appeler les services de police qui
vont pouvoir vérifier que le
renseignement est vrai se rend compte
que abdelhamid about et chakib acron
sont présents on pense qu'il est en
syrie à ce moment-là savons pas qui des
sur le territoire national oui bien sûr
ça choque et puis
je vois les quelques images qui ont été
prises par les services à ce moment là
[Musique]
mais la question c'est pourquoi on les
voit pas arriver est ce que c'est normal
pourquoi on rate about est-ce que c'est
logique je pense que ce sont des
questions sur lesquelles les juges vont
devoir s'arrêter en tout cas ce sont des
questions qu'on va poser
il ya cette impression effectivement
désagréable de se dire que y avait
toutes les pièces du puzzle les services
il avait une idée assez précise des
commandos qui s'apprêtait à frapper il
avait une idée assez précise de ce que
l'état islamique était en train de
préparer ils ne se sont pas fait duper
mais malheureusement sur certains
moments il arrive trop tard et c'est ce
trop tard fait 130 morts ou plus
ce qu'on découvre c'est que about
finalement n'a pas de base arrière c'est
qu'il est perdu s'il ne sait plus où
aller et qui se réfugient là où il peut
et
nous devons produire une opération de
mise hors d'état de nuire d'individus
qui peut frapper encore
les surveiller suivi lorsqu'il par
hasani en sortant de son but son souhait
très très bien cette cette nuit où je
suis tout seul
dans la bibliothèque de beauvau
directeur général de la sécurité
intérieure patrick calvar me tiens
informé par téléphone quasiment en
direct lorsque ses collaborateurs voit
dans les voitures qui filent véhicule d'
about
[Musique]
donc je suis ça vraiment minute par
minute
nous avons logé si je puis dire about
nous savons exactement où il est mais
nous savons où ils allaient se cacher
dans ce squat ça ne s'est jamais facile
de faire une opération comme celle qui a
été menées pour neutraliser about parce
que c'est en pleine ville de saint-denis
donc nous avons avec le ministère de
l'intérieur fait en sorte que
l'opération soit
finalement efficace possible
c'est-à-dire neutraliser about sans
qu'il y ait la moindre
conséquence pour le voisinage
[Musique]
l'assaut est donc terminée hassan il ya
un petit peu plus de l'été probablement
le cerveau de belges abdelhamid about a
donc été tués irma tard à saint denis
pendant l'assaut des forces de police et
puis dernières informations c'est que
abdelhamid about qui a rejoint donc cet
appartement de saint denis près pareil
effectivement un attentat un projet
d'attentât imminent puisqu'il aurait pu
avoir lieu le mercredi ou le jeudi et
qui devait se passer à la défense
la frustration moi je les jeux l'est
parce que about a été tué dans l'est à
saint-denis et pas dans les nappes a été
arrêté dans l'est dans les
four et c'est about dont j'ai besoin je
veux c'est lui qui doit m'apporter des
réponses depuis janvier 2015 il est dans
l'est dans les dents le
comme on dit ça le collimateur donc on
sait c'est le personnage que j'aurais
voulu
parce que je pense que pour nous oui
regardez dans les yeux voilà je pense
que pour certaines d'entre nous un
procès c'est ça le 18 novembre je crois
que c'est la deuxième fois que j'ai
allumé la télévision c'était le matin et
je devais aller travailler et je suis
pas aller travailler
je suis resté au sidéré 2h ou 3h devant
ma télé quoi et je me suis dit est ce
que c'est la fin d'une enquête
est-ce que s il y en a d'autres qui
qu'ils étaient le matin du 18 novembre
2015 alors que l'assaut du raid est
encore en cours celui qui a fourni
l'appartement aux terroristes clame son
innocence 2 pour notre caméra alors moi
demander de rendre service j'ai rendu
service monsieur on m'a dit des bergers
de personnes pendant 3 ou gérant du
service tant mieux je sais pas d'où il
vient le congrès monsieur si jamais vous
croyez que les hors énergie
à partir du moment où il va falloir se
prononcer sur le sort de cet individu
pour une éventuelle mise en examen le
parquet a l'obligation d'ouvrir une
information judiciaire donc le président
du tribunal intervient pour la
désignation des juges d'instruction
devant l'immensité de la tâche bah il
voit grand et il décide effectivement de
désigner six juges d'instruction qui
vont effectivement s'organise et se
coordonner de se partager la tâche
le parquet nous le dit on va arriver
avec presque déjà une vingtaine de tom
constitué il faut savoir que 20 hommes
c'est en gros la moyenne des tomes de
dossiers fini à l'antiterrorisme et là
on sait quand on commence on va voir
maintenant je me souviens de leur avoir
dit chers collègues la france vous
regarde
[Musique]
on
le travail d'un juge d'instruction
antiterroriste consiste à enquêter sur
les faits dont il est saisi et dire à la
fin de son enquête s'il y a suffisamment
d'éléments pour que les personnes à qui
les faits ont été imputés
soit ou non jugé jamais six juges
d'instruction avait été désigné sur un
même dossier c'est une connaissance
toujours une première dans l'histoire
c'est christophe teissier qui est
décisionnaire mais on se répartit le
travail de manière thématique c'est à
dire qu'il y en a un qui va se charger
de toutes les expertises génétiques qui
sont très nombreuses le 2 1 secondes
toutes les expertises balistiques
d'autres des victimes etc on se répartit
le dossier de manière thématique au
moins dans un premier temps pour faire
face à l'urgence
[Musique]
on se trouve et nous devant hiatus qu'on
avait peu connu les faits sont commis en
france
mais on s'aperçoit assez rapidement que
très peu de choses préparatoires ont été
commis en france et que donc c'est une
enquête qui obligatoirement passera par
une coopération internationale a promis
titre évidemment avec la belgique et
notamment un moyen qui a été créée
relativement récemment qui est ce qu'on
appelle l'équipe comme une banquette
mais l'équipe communaux qui permet je
dis toujours permet aux policiers
français de devenir des policiers belges
des policiers belges tenue des policiers
français quand un collègue français
travaillent avec moi dans une procédure
en belgique les actes que nous posons
ensemble ont directement valeur d'actes
de procédure en france avec pour
conséquence un gain temps et un gain
d'efficacité qui est tout à fait
considérable
[Musique]
lorsque nous commençons donc été nous
n'avons personne en face de nous quand
vous n'avez personne devant vous il faut
pallier cette absence de personnes et on
le palis par les examens techniques
qu'est ce que ces éléments le premier
élément c'est une image vidéo au stade
de france qui montre à 21h01 l'un des
terroristes kamikazes stade de france un
téléphone à la main
deuxième élément c'est un téléphone
qu'on va trouver dans la poubelle devant
le bataclan qui est en fait le téléphone
de l'un des terroristes est ces
investigations téléphoniques vont
permettre de démontrer que l'un des
quinze mille appels du stade de france
et le boîtier de la poubelle du bataclan
ont activé la même cellule téléphonique
en belgique
on tire un fil en fait parce qu'on part
par exemple d'un texto qui part du
bataclan en disant on y va il parle de
ça des gps mais effectivement aussi de
la téléphonie de l'achat des cartes sim
parfois vous avez des limete personnes
qui sont en contact avec un numéro et on
se rend compte qu'ils sont en contact
avec ce numéro à des moments
problématique ces numéros de téléphone
on est en contact avait d'autres numéros
tlf année encore avec d'autres numéros
tête ce qui a permis d'avoir une deux
d'avoir une énorme toile mais qui nous a
permis à certains moments de pouvoir
localiser les bases
mon sort atos dans l'actualité ce soir
des milliers de policiers mobilisés en
belgique mais aussi en ce d'ailleurs ce
matin une très vaste opération de police
a eu lieu dans ce quartier des unités
d'élite armés lourdement cagoulés
équipés de gilet pare balles en tout cas
ce week-end énormément de perquisitions
sept personnes interpellées sur ces sept
personnes deux ont été écroués nous
décidons de
d'intervenir sur pratiquement toutes les
pistes et des dossiers que nous avions
pour éviter qu'il se passe quelque chose
par rapport à des informations qu'elle
est services de renseignement avait reçu
dans l'immédiat on a lancé un enfant sur
le terrain et dans les premiers jours on
a fait 120 perquisition un sixième
suspect a été placé sous mandat d'arrêt
hier il s'agirait de mohamed bakkali pas
de confirmation du parquet fédéral sur
son identité mais l'inculpé serait bien
en lien avec la maison perquisitionnée
cette semaine à auvelais mame el bakkali
où on en a parlé lors de l'attentât du
thalys parce que c'est lui qui a
certainement convoyé de le terroriste du
thalys et abdelamid about quand ils sont
revenus en europe depuis la route des
migrants il va participer à la
préparation des attentats en fait il va
allouer les appartements il va louer des
voitures il va faire des trajets nous
savons que les véhicules loués sont
équipés de gps donc c'est autant de
renseignements qui sont utilisés dans le
cas de nos enquêtes
en remontant la piste bakkali et des
choses qu'il a pu louer et de ce qu'il a
pu faire et on va recommencer à
retrouver les différentes caches à
bruxelles
il y en a qui ont servi spécifiquement
la préparation des explosifs qui ont
servi de lieu de vie il y en a qui ont
été abandonnées parce qu'elle était
comme on dit cramer ou que ça sentait
pas bon il se doutait qu'il y avait des
problèmes donc ils se déplaçaient de
cash en cash
il ya un incident de préparation des
explosifs qui est à schaerbeek qui a vu
en ribère g qui était l'endroit
principale où était fabriqué les
explosifs qui vont servir pour le 13
novembre et pour le 22 mars également
louées par bakkali au 1er septembre
de l'instant où abdeslam retourne à
bruxelles jusqu'au mois de mars l'équipe
sur place fabrique de l'explosif en
quantité extrêmement important c'est du
tat p&c l'explosif qu'on retournait dans
les ceintures explosives qui ont été
utilisées au bataclan et on parle de
plusieurs centaines de kilos avec comme
maître d'oeuvre un garçon qui s'appelle
najib nasraoui qui a été formé par un
artificier de l'état islamique et qui
était le patron des jolies et des otages
à un moment effectivement lors des
perquisitions on trouve certains
éléments qui sont analysés certaines
cash est évident mais nous ont permis
quand même d'avoir certains éléments
intéressants d'autres cachent ont été
abandonnés un peu dans la précipitation
celle là nous ont permis d'avoir
énormément d'éléments intéressants et
qui permet de rebondir et encore
rebondir quand les policiers font des
perquisitions en remontant la piste dia
mohamed bakkali ils vont découvrir des
adn ils vont découvrir des adn des
membres des commandos du 13 millions
contre découvrir d'autres adn
[Musique]
et la première pensée des équipes à ce
moment là c'est il reste des membres de
commandos cons qu'ils ne sont pas morts
lors des attentats et qui était présent
avec des commandos du 13 novembre
ensemble à préparer une opération
conspiratives où sont-ils que vont-ils
faire
[Musique]
on
oh
oui on a peur qui se passe quelque chose
on sait que ce sont des éléments
incontrôlables ce sont des gens qui ont
qui sont poussés par une idéologie qui
leur a fait tuer 130 personnes à paris
voulez vous qu'ils seraient tous les
attentats de paris se sont produits une
partie des membres des cellules ont été
tués ou interpellés mais ça ne veut pas
dire que qu'il n'y a pas d'autre suspect
les enquêteurs se rendent compte en fait
que les terroristes ont fait faire toute
une série de fausses cartes d'identité
[Musique]
grâce à cette fausse identité on a pu
faire un travail policier identifier les
lieux qu'ils ont louée avec ces fausses
identités c'est un film aussi que les
enquêteurs suivaient c'est comme ça
qu'ils découvrent la maison à forest
[Musique]
on est entraînés on s'y prépare mais la
réalité est toujours différente c'est
toujours quand même une confrontation
est un choc
[Musique]
le 15 mars 2016 on a affaire à une
localisation froide différents éléments
tout à fait concret nous atteste du fait
que cette
cet appartement conspiratives ne doit
plus être occupé les enquêteurs ils vont
demander au rez-de-chaussée au voisin
est ce qu'il ya encore quelqu'un au
dessus pour les voisins c'est pas clair
il voit de temps en temps quelqu'un mais
les gens ils sont gentils humains ils
font pas de bruit etc il monta laitages
il
toque à la porte il ya personne
apparemment qui vient ouvrir puis ils
défoncent la porte les enquêteurs et là
il tombe donc sur ben salah abdeslam
accompagné de sofiane ayari et de
mohamed belkaïd mohamed belkaïd elite
présent syrie depuis très longtemps
c'est clairement quelqu'un qui est très
aguerri et un gros poisson de l'état
islamique il y en a un des trois qui
ouvre directement le feu et qui tirent
sur les collègues français et belges
[Musique]
un collègue et toucher son arme est
touché et son holster de ceinture est
touché donc il a eu le collègue vraiment
eu beaucoup de chance ils sont acculés
et il arrive à partir et à s'évacuer la
force de réaction rapide qui est
stationné dans la caserne est avisé et
part dans les minutes qui suivent après
la demande radio pour se diriger vers la
rue du driss à forer
il ya une espèce de fort chabrol qui ce
qui se crée
ou c'est surtout belkaïd qui tire
pendant que
ayari sofiane est sale abdeslam
s'échappe par l'arrière
[Musique]
la force de réaction y rentrer dans
l'immeuble est un des trois qui est
belle kate se trouvant encore dans
l'appartement et quand le premier le
chef d'equipe passe sa tête vous faire
une fouille c'est là qu'ils tirent et
tire une rafale en fait kalachnikov une
des balles touche le collègue donc là on
a un blessé qui t'ont
dans l'assaut il est évacué il est
retiré de la maison et là on se rend
compte qu'on est tombé sur un gars qui
lui n'a pas pris la fuite et il est là
et si les décider qui va pas se laisser
faire
[Musique]
ça dure encore deux heures deux heures
et demie entre temps il ya des centaines
de coups de feu qui sont données parce
que le gars ne se rend pas finalement
il apparaît une ou deux fois devant la
fenêtre en front de rue et il ya un de
nos tireurs d'élite qui a une fenêtre
pour la batterie la bad dans l'ouverture
de fenêtres
[Musique]
sur place ils retrouvent des prolos qui
sont bien des choses c'est à dire des
drapeaux noirs à l'éffigie de dèche
des munitions retrouve d'aider des
chargeurs de kalachnikov donc c'est bien
clair que c'est une plan pour salah qui
l'y a été il retrouve de l'adn il était
là mais on est
très court délai lui donc on on exerce
une réelle pression on est très proches
ils nous sans il sent qu'on est derrière
et d'ailleurs ça va déterminer la suite
des investigations
ça remet l'église au milieu du village
en disant non les gars ils sont bien ici
il ya encore au moins une de cellules
ici ils sont préparés
[Musique]
mais salah ben des slams va être victime
si j'ose dire du professionnalisme de
cette cellule terroriste c'est à dire
que les terroristes pour préserver
l'intégrité de la cellule terroriste
si l'un d'eux tombe en fait il en ciel
moins possible en quittant sa planque
refuge
abdeslam ignore tout de la planque
refuge de l'autre partie du groupe et
donc il se retrouve livré à lui même il
n'a pas d'autre planque où aller et donc
il va appeler un petit ami que les
policiers belges ont déjà mis sur écoute
au lendemain du 13 novembre ça va
permettre de remonter jusqu'à la halle
des slams et l'interpeller
[Musique]
les enquêteurs font leur font très bien
leur boulot ils jettent leur fils est
bien loin pour aller
aller pêcher ce qui ce qui a empêché
finalement il est logé rue des
quatre-vents à molenbeek-saint-jean
parce que ils voient qu'il ya plus
d'activité dans les autres endroits où
ils pouvaient se trouver
[Musique]
la presse belge où certains organes de
presse belges sont au courant et on leur
demande de se taire l'info ne sort
finalement que le vendredi par un
journal français et a eu
alors que nous avions prévu d'intervenir
de façon sécurisée au milieu de la nuit
et c'est là nous sommes obligés
d'intervenir dans un quartier à grosse
majorité musulmane à la sortie de la
prière à la sortie des écoles c'était un
vrai cauchemar ça aurait put ça aurait
pu très mal tourner
vous savez dans ce genre de dossier il
ya tellement de personnes qui sont au
courant qu'il y avait quand même souvent
des fuites et donc quand on est arrivés
sur place il y avait deux équipes de
télévision qui était dont une qui était
quasi devant sa porte
recul et beaucoup y a des possibilités
y avait-il des dorures les grecs et
turcs oui mon équipe donc on est passés
par l'arrière on est passé par la cour
de l'école puis par les toits on a
traversé la cour de récréation et il
lâche 2 de nos grimpeurs qui sont avec
moi dans l'équipe voit un bonhomme
sortir avec une casquette habillés en
noir qui crie police mes collègues et là
il se rend compte qu'un et regarde vers
le haut il se rend compte que à mon avis
qu'il est encerclée et repart dans
l'autre sens
[Musique]
donc le collègue voit une ombre qui sort
dans le couloir qui est tournée il a mis
sa capuche et il est tourné dos vers la
porte et il recule mon collègue donne
fait les sommations donne les
injonctions veux qu'ils se retournent
qui lève les bras là il se retourne il
est quasi nez à nez avec le collègue
mais ils sont pas vraiment directement
en légitime défense est là il sort et il
sort en courant
[Musique]
salam des flammes il n'était pas rentré
dans la salle du bataclan
c'est pas une des personnes qui est
rentré dans la salle du bataclan et qui
nous a tiré dessus pour moi ces
personnes là sont mortes et donc j'ai du
mal au début à mme
[Musique]
à bien à bien me rendre compte de
l'importance du fait que sa large part
été c'était une bonne surprise
notamment qui se fasse arrêter vivent
donc on s'est retrouvés vraiment avec un
des auteurs principaux clairement
identifiés arrêtés et qui sera présent
le box des accusés donc tout de suite ça
donnait un procès qui était déjà hors
norme par le nombre de lieux touchés le
style de l'attak le nombre de pages du
dossier ça à lui donner une consistance
vraiment lui-même
le dernier membre du commando du 13
novembre est arrêté vivant et c'est le
sol vivant des membres du xiii qui est
qui est arrêté donc c'est une victoire
pour les services belges ils arrêtent en
plus un membre qui faisait partie du
commando mais qui n'était pas présent à
parler à ce moment là et il espère
pouvoir retrouver surtout très
rapidement les autres zones membres qui
correspondent aux adn qu'ils ont
retrouvé dans les différents sites
belges
[Musique]
de toute façon on savait que la fin de
la traite de sale abdeslam sa marquaient
pas la fin de la cellule le risque était
effectivement que ces personnes ne
bouffe qui sentait que l'étau se
resserrait autour d'elle ne commette un
acte pour finir en beauté parce que pour
eux finir en beauté c'est le faire le
plus de victimes possible dans la
population civile
quand on retourne quelques jours avant
dans la rue du driss il ya un enquêteur
que je connais de vue qui commence à
discuter avec moi et lui il parle des
frères bakr a oui
les frères bakr a oui nous on a
travaillé dessus pour des faits de grand
banditisme
hindisheim notamment même dit les bacs
raoui on ne sait pas où ils sont et ça
me fait un peu peur le 13 novembre
n'était pas la fin de l'opération
l'arrestation d'abdeslam n'est pas la
fin de l'opération c'est toujours un
groupe qui va muter jusqu'à ce qu'il ait
plus personne
les deux coordinateurs
survivants de la cellule terroriste sont
nagy me lâchera wii est un des frères el
batraoui échange avec le chef de la
cellule des opex qui est lui à jaca
il explique que c'est fini pour eux donc
il faut se dépêcher il n'y a pas d'autre
solution que de passer à l'acte
la situation est telle qu'on ne peut
plus on peut plus retarder quoi que ce
soit tu vois on doit travailler le plus
vite possible et on a décidé de
travailler inch'allah demain mardi 22
mars en matinée parce qu'on a plus de
planck de sécurité il n'y a plus
personne et cetera il n'y a plus deux
frères pour la logistique tout le monde
est cramé tu vois
[Musique]
au matinée il y à des vins l'américain
des vols russes dévoile israël on va
essayer de les toucher lisse il se sera
inchallah l'aéroport et les lignes de
métro tu vois direct et ça se termine là
dessus
[Musique]